you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays a
lot of attention to latin america one of
the least covered regions in the world
perhaps that is why many of you have
often asked us to talk more about latin
america well
we've got a solution
[Music]
we're proud to present latam politik a
newsletter that we have prepared
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you will receive
12 newsletters with the best information
and analysis
on latin america to keep you up to date
and better understand everything that is
happening in this region the cost
you can subscribe for less than 35 cents
per newsletter
less than a small taco or a donut a week
in return
you'll be kept up to date on all major
happenings in the region and better
understand
all the possible implications in
addition all of you who support us at
patreon level four and five
will receive latin politic at zero cost
you can find all the info
at latimpolitik.com
[Music]
dear friends if i were to ask you what
you think about what is known as the
welfare
state that is public services in china
i'm pretty sure that we would have two
main options some of you would likely
think that it must be a
huge welfare system super welfare with
lots of coverage and
free things covered by the government
after all china
is in theory a socialist country but
others might think that the opposite is
true that surely there are practically
none of these things at all in the asian
super nation that we are talking about a
country that is obsessively focused on
reducing labor costs and that no matter
how socialist it may claim to be when it
comes down to it
the worker has no more status than that
of a production machine well to all of
you who have either of these views
i'm sorry to say that you're both wrong
the idea we have today of a welfare
state that is a series of social
insurance and coverage paid in whole
or in part by the state did not exist in
china until the 1990s and initially
began as an experiment
at the local level in fact in the land
of the red dragon the role of the state
as guarantor of minimum social
protection
is a recent development and does not
resemble either european or east asian
systems
what's more if we were to make a
comparison perhaps one of the most
similar systems would be
paradoxically that of the united states
yes that's what i said now what exactly
does the welfare state of the people's
republic of china look like
how has it evolved over the recent
decades to answer these questions dear
friends
the first thing to do is to start of
course at the beginning
so yes that means it's also time to say
let's look at some history
a system in constant evolution
[Music]
the chinese welfare state let's call it
that for the sake of simplicity did not
really exist as we know it now
until the 1990s in any case it could be
said that it has gone through
three periods the first which was
enforced between 1949 and 1978 was known
as the central planning period
and is the one that characterized mao
zedong's social policies
the second is often referred to as the
pro-growth economic policy and lasted
from 1978 to 2003 and the third and
current one
is known as social harmony what's behind
all these fancy names well you see
the first one the central planning was a
pseudo-welfare system
inspired by the soviet union to be a
fundamental part of the construction of
a socialist economy as a consequence
since unemployment was seen as a defect
of capitalism the regime
assigned employment to all able-bodied
chinese citizens of working age
lifetime employment in state enterprises
and agencies government departments
collective farms
and so on and so forth
these work units were called downway and
were organized under the formula of
state enterprises or cooperatives a sort
of self-sufficient mini welfare state
was organized around them consisting of
three main elements
lifetime known as the iron rice bowl
equal pay
and a social assistance package latter
was managed directly by each dan way and
provided unit workers with housing
access to education healthcare stores
and other services
but wait a minute because while all this
may sound more or less positive keep in
mind that we're talking about the china
where 89
of the people lived in extremely poor
rural areas where there was not even
enough food for everyone so the quality
of these services
well as you can imagine it left a lot to
be desired moreover the fact that
lifetime employment
housing and a series of social services
linked to the damn way were provided was
not at all altruistic
in this way the maoist regime ensured
also thanks to the huco system that it
controlled where the population lived
and what they worked on
not only that the hoko gave the regime
the ability to move huge masses of labor
from the countryside to the cities to
meet the needs of
industry a sector that mao was promoting
in the image of the soviet five-year
plans
so what exactly is hookup well it is
basically a unique chinese family
registration system
and although it has evolved somewhat in
practice it has always served to
establish a huge barrier to
for example moving by choice from the
countryside to the city as well as
linking social services to the place of
birth
instead of the whole country or the
place where you work that is
despite being a chinese citizen in
practice you may only have a right to
health care or education or unemployment
or a pension in one place but not in any
other something that has affected and
continues to affect workers who migrate
from the countryside to the cities
[Music]
we will talk about all this a little
later on the point is that by 1978
china had already suffered several
economic and political crises and was
also lagging
far behind the asian tigers hong kong
taiwan singapore and south korea and in
that very same year as we've already
covered in a video that i'll link in the
description a series of reformist
politicians came to power led by
deng xiaoping and yes in addition to
carrying out the now famous reforms
towards state capitalism or towards a
kind of market socialism call it what
you want it also modified the system of
social benefits that to put it bluntly
no longer fits with the new system that
was to be put in place
[Music]
you see along with the dismantling of
collective structures after the economic
reforms social protection for the
villagers disappeared
including the old health cooperatives
most rural clinics became private and
many low-income rural people were left
unable to access even basic healthcare
in the cities the policy of forced full
employment was replaced in 1986
by individual contracts and companies
were relieved of their welfare
obligations
this meant that at first many surplus
workers were laid off leaving them
highly vulnerable thus
increasing urban poverty in addition
mao's idea that economic growth was
directly dependent on population growth
made this transition much worse
and more difficult because suddenly
there was a lot of surplus human capital
which was immediately corrected with
policies such as the one child policy
established in 1979
[Music]
the fact is that by the end of the 80s
the regime had been focused for too many
years on internal political reforms
leaving aside the social situation of a
population that had not had a great time
before and was now having an even worse
time dealing with all the changes that
were being implemented as you know
changes usually entail a transition
period
especially when those changes are very
gradual and slow but carry a lot of
significance
[Music]
not surprisingly social unrest strikes
and the risk of political collapse posed
by the reforms towards state capitalism
that had just been set in motion
forced the government to design a new
welfare system with a simple pragmatic
vision let's say that the majority
political understanding at the time was
that if all these social needs were not
addressed as soon as possible
and violence crime and conflict
increased not only could the reforms be
derailed but the very power of the
chinese communist party could collapse
so by the late 80s and early 90s the
state stopped focusing on political
reforms and started to give priority to
the issue of social protection
of course in a very very different
manner from what those of you who are
watching us from old europe are used to
[Music]
at that time a social security system
was established with the intention of
reducing the burden of care for the
dunway so that together with businesses
the employees and the state would also
share the costs this in itself would
also help boost the competitiveness of
chinese corporations
at the end of 1991 a housing provident
fund a compulsory savings fund was
created first in shanghai and then in
1995 at the national level with the
objective of facilitating people's
access to housing in the same vein
low interest loans were also established
for mortgage loans in 1994 labor law
introduced a new welfare state framework
that included among other things
a system of public subsidies for the
poorest social welfare payments and
compulsory individual superannuation
savings accounts to complement the
public pension system
as you can see all these increases in
social support in china are relatively
recent
as much of the current system was built
in the 1990s however the truth is that
all these reforms despite their reduced
scope played an essential role both in
consolidating the power of the communist
party
and in boosting and settling the middle
class now at this point i'm sure many of
you are already wondering okay
okay this is all well and good but what
exactly does the chinese welfare system
look like now what is left of the past
and how does it work in the present well
let's take a look
[Music]
not as socialist as you thought
let's be honest describing the chinese
welfare system is a titanic task because
more than being one system it is a
system of systems with different
coverage
benefits and privileges depending on
where you live and what fields you work
in but to simplify it we can say that
the current system is organized into
three pillars
social assistance social insurance and
welfare services
first social assistance is direct aid to
the poorest people and its main
component is the minimum livelihood
guarantee
a kind of minimum cash income managed by
local authorities and which differs
according to the area where the
individual lives
incidentally the majority of chinese
workers who migrate from rural areas to
cities for work
are excluded from this assistance
secondly we have the social security
system which is a very difficult puzzle
to manage and is under the central
government spotlight due to successive
corruption scandals and a lack of
control over funds and beneficiaries
this system is composed of several
insurance and pension plans
for example we have the basic retirement
pension which covers up to 60
of the salary that was earned while
working as long as the individual has
contributed for more than 15 years it is
a graduated system i.e if you have only
contributed 15 years you receive around
of your former salary as a pension and
for each additional year of
contributions
this percentage increased by one percent
this pension system is financed through
employee and
employer contributions then there is a
parallel system of rural pensions
similar to the company system but with a
collective subsidy from the government
that replaces the employer's
contribution in addition these pensions
are lower than those of the company
system
[Music]
but it doesn't end there there is also a
lot to be untangled on the issue of
health insurance which is yet more
gibberish this insurance is actually
composed of at least three different
types
for other urban employees and for rural
cooperatives the latter created in 2003
is voluntary and has enabled 97
of rural population to have access to
healthcare health insurance is also paid
with contributions from the worker and
the employer but perhaps the most
surprising feature for many of you is
that in china there is no universal and
free healthcare at least not in the way
that there is in some countries in for
example
europe
[Music]
in fact despite being covered by health
insurance there is a health co-payment
whereby the public health insurance only
covers about 60
of the costs what's more medical centers
do not necessarily have to be public
in fact there is a growing network of
private hospitals and clinics throughout
china then of course there is also
private
health insurance which is becoming more
and more common and often serves as a
compliment to improve the quality of
care and cover the part of the
co-payment that is not subsidized by the
state insurance
and yes in china women also have paid
maternity leave with a 98-day leave paid
by employers and which compensates for
the loss of income during maternity
leave but let's move on in china there
is also
unemployment insurance jointly financed
by the worker and the employer as in
most countries it covers up to 24 months
with basic assistance and depending on
the location
may or may not include medical expenses
finally there is the third pillar which
is welfare services aimed at the poorest
the orphans the disabled and the most
disadvantaged elderly well in theory
these are the pillars of the welfare
system that the chinese government
offers as you can see
it is much more lacks an externalized
system than you would expect in a
supposedly socialist country and that's
not all because as you know
theory is one thing and practice is
another listen up
[Music]
a model riddled with holes
the chinese welfare system if we think
about it as a public social system in a
country that wants to be something like
the champion of a social system
overcoming capitalism has two big
problems
it still covers too few people and it is
very discriminatory look for example at
this graph
as you can see of all urban workers less
than 70
pay pension contributions only 44 pay
unemployment benefits and barely half
pay health insurance but if this already
seems too little look at what happens
with migrant workers
only 22 pay pension contributions the
same percentage for health insurance and
only omega 17
participate in unemployment insurance
according to the chinese government data
but hold on a minute how
does what we're telling you fit in with
headlines like this over 95
of people in china have basic medical
insurance cgtn
well the truth is that these headlines
are not lies but they're not exactly
true either for example migrant workers
with their huco in rural areas of origin
are technically covered by the rural
cooperative medical system but are not
covered in the urban areas where they
live and work that is it may be true
that 95
of the chinese population is covered by
some form of health insurance but the
percentage
that can actually benefit from the
coverage where they work is much lower
and take note because this is not
something that can be overlooked
at the end of 2019 for example there
were nearly 300 million chinese migrant
workers who had left the countryside for
the city in order to improve their
standard of living so you can imagine
how many people are left out of the
chinese government welfare system
[Music]
in other words around one-sixth of the
chinese population is exposed to higher
levels of precariousness than their
population registered in urban hokule
however another thing to note is that
the situation is very convenient for the
government as it keeps statistics sky
high without the need to provide
additional funds
after all if 300 million people have
moved from countryside to the city you
don't need to provide health
infrastructure for all these people as
they're technically covered in their
places of origin these guys could make
the disastrous nicolic operation
profitable even if it meant deducting
hypothetical revenues from potential
future customers you never know
and let's add that if you don't have a
formal contract you are excluded from
social services beyond your place of
origin do you understand the problem now
on the other hand another challenge as
mentioned before lies in the management
of the system itself
even several of the chinese government's
own audits confirm that the welfare
system is riddled with irregularities
irregularities such as the failure of
many companies to contribute the
improper payment of benefits to
ineligible persons
and the misappropriation by local
authorities of social security funds
for other purposes nevertheless china's
welfare system according to official
statistics
is in surplus although these same
statistics show that the system
especially the pension system faces a
serious problem of viability due to the
lack of capital accumulation
or in other words although there are
individual mandatory savings accounts
in practice the pension system basically
functions as a pay-as-you-go system
whereby as today's contributions
cover today's needs the initial idea was
to create a system similar to chiles or
singapore's where mandatory savings
funds and social contributions
were capitalized but this has not yet
been achieved
so there you have it the broad outline
of the welfare state in the people's
republic of china it is an
insurance-based system with a strong
presence of private players in the
provision of services which in general
terms is more similar to the u.s system
than to those of the european social
democracies a model by the way with very
few public benefits and one that is
subject to many limitations making a
large number of chinese citizens
basically excluded that said the
economic growth that china has recorded
since reforms were first launched in
1978 has not only led to an incredible
reduction in poverty
and a huge improvement in the living
standards of chinese families but has
also allowed news like this to happen
25th of february 2021 xi jinping
declares extreme poverty
has been wiped out in china president
says 850 million people have been lifted
out of destitution in an unprecedented
accomplishment scmp but at this point
it's your turn what do you think of the
current chinese welfare state did you
expect it to be like this or did you
imagine that it would be much more
public and state-run let us know your
thoughts below in the comments
and if you liked this video don't forget
to like and subscribe to the channel
once again
thank you for watching take care and
i'll see you next time and if you want
to learn more about politics and hear
even more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there